In storytelling, especially in film, a visual medium, it is show,
not tell people don't take in information, um,
or they take it in much better.
If it's the information is in service to a story that touches their
hearts. And, um, so the, you know,
science tells us that the most effective storytelling is one,
one that, um, is, is, is human centered around people.
People we care about, we identify with, we relate to, um, and,
um, we release oxytocin when we watch something about someone we
care about and that is the love hormone. It it's, it's what makes us,
um, feel, um, attracted to somebody. It's the,
it's the hormone we secrete when we kiss, when we breastfeed, when we have sex,
when we hug, when.
Like videos of our kids as like the one that.
Exactly you feel warm and fuzzy,
it actually changes your body chemistry.
And then the story needs to be structured in a way where there's some tension
and rising tension. And if so,
that's what captures our attention and holds our attention because we secrete
cortisol and cortisol is, um, it's over Ramon.
That is from our, um, the amygdala, the fear center. And, um,
it's what, what, um, heightens our attention. Um,
so if you have rising tension in a story and you
have people who are relatable, the cortisol grabs the attention,
keeps your attention because I mean, we're in an attention starved world,
but even before social media and all these other things,
our brains are prone to wander, but you want someone engaged.
So it engages our brains. It engages our heart. And then after if,
if I believe strongly in structuring stories that well,
the classic story structure from like ancient times to today is there's
someone, that person has a goal.
There are obstacles in the way the person has to struggle to reach the goal.
We have to understand what's at stake, the bigger the stakes,
the harder it is to reach the goal.
The more we identify with the person and root for them,
the more we go on that emotional journey with them, which is actually, um,
if you, if you, um, study people's brains, when they're hooked on the story,
they actually, their brains, um, act like a participant,
not a spectator. So you can actually bring someone on an emotional journey.
And then if you end on triumph, they reach the goal.
You leave your viewer feeling, wow, I can do that too.
Um, and then it also releases dopamine,
which is kind of the reward center from the reward center of our brain.
So it leaves us feeling optimistic and hopeful. So, um, that's, that is.
So it sounds like you start with oxytocin and then you get to cortisol and then
you hope to leave them with dopamine.
Right. But you end the way to do that is to, um,
tell stories about somebody.
The viewer cares about whether it's the candidate, uh,
telling his or her own personal story where we care about the
person. Um, and that person's struggle.
Uh, it could be personal struggle.
It could be struggle of why they care so deeply about why they're
running or a certain issue, and then ending with a sense of hope.
Because if you leave people with no hope,
then they're not going to feel like they should take any action,
because if they're not going to be able to achieve their goal,
then why bother? You know, you want to, and which is, yeah.
One of the criticisms, you know, I had, and like I struggled with,
we've all seen those cheesy political ads. It's like, you know,
it was a black and white photo and it's like, I grew up like a, you know, the,
the son of a cobbler or like the, like that, that,
that the daughter of a, um, Datcher or what, you know, I mean,
I'm making that up. Cause I don't think we have bachelors anymore, but
it's like, uh, like where,
where you make the person relatable and then like you make it seem like they
overcame this hard Scrabble background.
And then like you have some uplifting photos of them. And like,
I personally have lost patients for those political ads.
And I know when you and I talked about this stuff,
like I struggled a little bit with trying to convey things in a
way that felt personal to me that just didn't feel like artifice
or it's like, okay, hit this beat. He hit that beat. Um,
because I feel like at this point,
people have just lost all patients with political ads and communication.
Um,
but it sounds like the things you were saying appear in a lot of these political
ads. So do political ads look the way they do because they work.
Uh, I don't, I don't know, but I think that execution it's always,
the devil is in the details, right? It's like what I'm laying out.
You can like any story you can execute well,
or you can execute poorly. So I crazy horrible.
They're out there, like sets out to make a bad movie,
but there are a lot of bad movies that get made.
Sure. And it's not paint by numbers.
It's not like there's no formula to follow.
It's really about for every single person finding what is most
genuine to them. Um, but that doesn't mean cheesy and cheesy,
cheesy as how something shot. It's the music,
it's the graphics it's cheesy is, um, you know,
it's a quality. And so I think that, um,
uh, you, you know, you, you want the, um,
the feeling of a video to reflect the identity and
feeling of the candidate not to, because everything, again, this,
I hate the word authenticity because it's so overused. But like you,
that is one of the many reasons Andrew, why you broke it out because you didn't,
you didn't study.
What do other politicians do and how do people running for office?
How w how am I supposed to behave? You didn't do that. You were,
you, you always showed up as you. Um.
Well, one thing that we found, uh,
early in the campaign when we were shooting various videos or appeals where the
most effective appeal was just me talking to my cell phone camera.
Um, I think because of what you're describing,
where it strikes people as very genuine and human,
because everyone talks to their, their phones. And so, uh,
it seemed like you couldn't fake anything.
And I think that that's something I've seen with younger
political figures where they seem really good at that. Uh, you know, I,
I'm not sure how excellent and Instagram soliloquy deliver I
am, uh, you know, in the scheme of things like, uh,
but I agree that just giving someone a glimpse into,
um, your moments on the trail or your, uh, you know,
like home or whatever it happens to be, uh,
like it makes them feel like they know you in a particular way. Um,
I think if a politician was not able to do that, um,
then it, it seems like there's something missing.
Well, I, you know, [inaudible] launch, uh, video was brilliant.
Um, it wasn't hugely polished, but that didn't matter. I mean,
in terms of how it was shot,
it actually probably was helpful that it felt so real. Um,
and it, it was, it was everything I just described in terms of,
you know, uh, her, her struggles, her journey, her why her, you know, her,
her being relatable, but it was, you know, um,
not cheesy. There was nothing cheesy about that video. So it's,
it's all about the execution. Um, uh, and,
and people being vulnerable, being themselves. I mean, you know, you,
you seal even studies about leadership and what
builds trust and what builds loyalty among a leader,
if that person has credibility.
And then that person is vulnerable and, and,
and shares that they're fallible,
or that they're scared about something or that, you know,
shares human emotion that we all have.
Then people see that person as human, not superhuman,
you don't want to be seen as superhuman because then you don't see them.
Most people probably would like to be seen as superhuman.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do to yang speaks.
And click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.